The result is the additive increase multiplicative
decrease congestion control algorithm. The algorithm is
distributed, meaning that all the senders can
act independently, and we've just shown using
the phase plots that it's both fair
and efficient. To visualize this sending rate
over time, the sender's sending rate looks roughly as shown. We call this the
TCP sawtooth behavior or simply the
TCP sawtooth. TCP periodically probes for available
bandwidth by increasing its rate using additive
increase. When the sender reaches a saturation
point by filling up a buffer in a router somewhere along the path, it will see
a packet loss, at which point it will decrease its sending rate
by half. You can thus see that a TCP sender sends, a sending rate shown by the
dotted green line that is halfway between the
maximum window size at which the sender sends, and
half that rate, which it backs off to when it sees a loss. You can see that
between the lowest sending rate and the highest
is w m over 2 plus 1 round trips.
Now given that rate we can compute the
number of packets between periods of packet loss,
and compute the loss rate from this. The
number of packets sent for every packet lost is
the area of this triangle. So the lost rate is on the order of the square
of the maximum window divided by some constant.
Now, the throughput is the average rate, 3 4ths
w max divided by the RTT. Now if we want to relate the throughput to the
loss rate, where we call the loss rate
p, and the throughput lambda, we simply need to
solve for w m. And I'm just going to get rid of the constant. So a loss
occurs once for this number of packets, so
the loss rate is simply 1 over that quantity.
And then when we solve for w m and plug in for throughput, we see that the
throughput is inversely proportional to both the round trip
time and the square root of the loss rate.